So we've been talking about how there's a
real question mark as to what right wing media
is going to look like over the next two years
and four years in the Biden presidency.
And we are if if there is any signal about
it over the last 24 to 48 hours, it's that
it's going to be absolutely and completely
nuts.
Now, we covered during the Trump administration
Fox Business host Maria Bartiromo, who used
to be a very solid reporter on CNBC 20 years
ago when I started watching CNBC as I got
into the financial markets and trading stocks
and the like.
And during the Trump administration, she became
nothing short of a complete and total Trump
brownnoser, doing sycophantic softball interviews
and repeating the most ridiculous conspiracy
theories, including over the last two months
that Donald Trump was going to figure out
a way to be sworn in for another four years
when clearly he was not.
And this week, she asserts without evidence
that at the January 6th Trump riots, there
were Democrats dressed up like Magga Trump
people.
There is no evidence of this.
This is as baseless as it was really antifa
in disguise.
It doesn't seem to affect Maria Bartiromo,
his willingness to repeat it.
Take a listen to this.
About security in the nation's capital is
at an unprecedented level this morning ahead
of the inauguration tomorrow.
And your report says that some far right protesters
have discussed posing as members of the National
Guard to infiltrate the inauguration the way
Democrats infiltrated two weeks ago and put
on maggot clothing.
Acting Secretary of Defense Chris Miller says
that there is no intelligence about a potential
insider threat to the inauguration.
So no one did that.
Democrats didn't do that.
That's a lie.
Black Lives Matter didn't dress up.
As Trump hosts on January 6th, Antifa didn't
dress up as Trump is on January 6th.
There's no evidence for that whatsoever.
And what I see here is Maria Bartiromo desperately
trying to have credibility and relevance,
but lying as usual, like Sean Hannity realizing,
wait a second, I used to be friends with the
president.
Now I'm not friends with the president anymore.
I'm out and she's looking for something to
cling to.
And this claim about storming the it was it
was Democrats in disguise storming the Capitol
on January 6th.
It's truly bonkers.
But what's really crazy is this four year
period of being a brownnosing Trump sycophant
and repeating the most ridiculous, baseless,
harebrained conspiracy theories.
It seems to have gotten Maria Bartiromo a
possible promotion.
Fox News has announced that six hosts are
going to get in formal week long tryouts to
become the permanent hosts of the seven p.m.
Eastern hour on Fox News, which they're going
to call Fox News primetime.
Maria Bartiromo is one of the hosts who's
going to get a week trial like an audition
of sorts.
And also getting auditions for the 7:00 p.m.
hour are Fox News contributors Katie Pavlik,
who's a disaster.
Rachel Campos Duffy, who I've never heard
of, former Congressman Trey Gowdy and commentator
Marc Stein.
I believe Fox and Friends host Brian Kilmeade
also is going to get a week trial for that
seven p.m. hour.
So they are setting up for the Biden presidency.
They're still trying to figure out what their
approach is going to be.
But if the last 48 hours are any indication,
the conspiracy theories will continue, the
hypocrisy will continue, and the attempted
brainwashing of their audience will continue.
And sadly, as I've said before, because of
the very, very low level of media literacy
in this country, it works on a lot of people
and it's often just a race.
Whoever gets the whoever programs them first,
it's very difficult to get them out of it.
And if you, quote, programed people to think
for themselves to have a high degree of media
literacy, to understand how to question where
they came to their conclusions, how they came
to hold the beliefs they hold, if that's the
programing people get, then you have people
who think for themselves and don't fall for
this nonsense.
If you program people that everybody else
is lying to you, you can only believe me,
which is common in right wing media.
And it was common to what Donald Trump, Donald
Trump would say.
You can't believe what you're seeing and hearing.
The news is fake.
Just believe me, if that's the initial programing
people get, particularly if they're already
adults, a ship has sailed so proverbially
speaking.
So it's going to be pretty wild for the next
couple of years.
And the other question will be, will be will
there be any degree of antagonism between
right wing media and what is left of the Republican
Party after Trump?
Left it in shambles and I want to talk about
that next a little bit